[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with Netflix
being flipped turned upside down due to
the events of stranger things 3 it's
time to break down the alternate
universe that the show centers around
throughout this video I'll be going over
everything that you need to know about
the upside-down and the characters that
inhabit it there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't seen all of
season 3 of stranger things then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into my breakdown of the
upside-down the upside-down was first
introduced in stranger things season 1
at the will buyers disappeared into the
dark dimension the upside-down is a Dark
Mirror antimatter version of our
universe that is inhospitable to humans
and is dangerous for all that venture
into it the landscape of the upside down
is just like our earth possessing
similar locales and landmarks however
human life is completely absent from it
due to the toxicity in the atmosphere
there's a shadowy aura to everything and
a ghoul like webbing that is attached to
almost every surface which highlights
the hive mind that exists there it's
almost like an even creepier version of
Silent Hill with ash in hive spores
flowing through every inch of oxygen
making it almost impossible to breathe
in whilst in season 1 it was simply an
alternate dimension that sprung forth
some dark and twisted creatures in
season 2 have begun seeping into our
world and infecting all life through
bleeding into our dimension by season 3
the mind flayer that ruled oh but the
dark world had begun amassing forces
through Billy in order to fully come
into our world and destroy all life
Russia had been secretly experimenting
in the area in order to open a doorway
to the alternate universe and his
further help to empower the mind flayer
but who created the upside down well
whilst we never had concrete answers
about who or what created the upside
down it's clear that the creatures that
live in it all have an obsession with
our world and
sprit to take over it the dimension was
initially discovered by accident and
Hawkins lab during experiments involving
11 and opening a gateway but none of the
creatures that live there have ever
explained anything about their world
even when possessing humans several
monsters exist in the upside down but
the most notable of these is the mind
flayer
this is the overlord of the area and due
to its ability to control other
creatures it is viewed as the ruler of
the upside down the mine fire possesses
psychic abilities and is even able to
control humans and influence them to do
its bidding which we see throughout
season 3 when forcing Billie to bring it
bodies it has successfully entered the
consciousness of will and 11 as well as
Billy all in its goal to take over the
world so how do you get to the upside
down well there are actually several
ways to get there though typically this
involves opening a portal in season 111
opened a portal in Hawkins lab which
allowed scientists and explorers to
venture into it and it also enabled
creatures from the dimension to break
through this allowed membranes to spread
throughout the city which could also be
used to step into the Otherworld we
witnessed this when 11 is pulled through
into the upside-down and can see through
the tears back into our world it's clear
that the dimension tears throughout the
town and during the three seasons it has
reached into several parts of the city
in season two Jim hopper traveled
through a large section of the town and
discovered that the universe had become
bleeding into our world under Hawkins
there existed a network of tunnels that
all tied directly back to a large portal
which 11 managed to close in the finale
however a part of the mine player
remained in Hawkins looking for a new
host after it was exorcised from will
which is when it latched on to Billy
through him it builds an army known as
the flayed that run rampant throughout
Hawkins in addition to this the Russians
were using a device to create another
tear so that more of the mind flayer
hosts in the upside down were able to
come back through by the end of season 3
with help from Jim hopper Joyce was able
to destroy the weapon that the Russians
had been using in their experiments and
closed the portal once and for all
hopper seemingly died in the explosion
brought forth by the weapon however it's
extremely possible that he instead use
the tear as protection and travel
through it into the upside down in order
to survive the machines destruction this
will explain how there's an American in
Russia in the season's post-credit scene
as they could have pulled them through
this doorway on the other side
what's so amazing about the dimension is
that it's still cloaked in a lot of
mystique and magic but one thing is
clear whoever comes into contact with it
is left either dead or haunted horrific
aliy by the things that they've seen
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the upside down and if there's
anything that you think should have been
included in the video and make sure you
let me know in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my full fan
Theory breakdown on Jim hoppers death at
the end of stranger things 3 which would
be linked at the end it goes over all of
the evidence to support the characters
still being alive and it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
what really happened to it I'll link
that at the end and hopefully I'll see
you over there after this this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you